stop [ __ ] yes okay so maybe you can
start right so yeah it's it's great to
see you all here this is this lecture
series that we nicknamed summer camp on
boolean functions it's sort of meant to
highlight the recent exciting
advancement in the area that happened
over the past few years it's really
remarkable to see all these
long-standing conjectures being you know
resolved one after the other and we have
a great lineup so this is today will be
the first talk the schedule has been
changed a bit over the last few days
because of some conflicts that we had
with ccc so this is the updated schedule
i hope that it would not change after
that so the first talk is today by tour
next week we would have how talking
about the sensitivity conjecture and
then we'll have a break of one week
because of ccc and then the following
week would have two lectures one by sha
hole of it on improve bounds on the
sunflower lemma and another by one and
done you know using stochastic calculus
to resolve open questions in boolean
function analysis the week after that
would go and I have SDL man about a new
true for the KKL inequality via random
restriction and then we'll have pre
Hitomi talking about pseudo-random
generators from random walks this is the
plan currently the reason we stopped is
that this semester when simon starts
immediately after august 18th so we
didn't want to clash with that it might
be the case if we would add some
lectures after that but this is the
current plan
okay so anyway the website now is
updated and you can see the listen you
will see abstract of every Rick talk so
maybe we should start with today's talk
a person do you have anything okay so we
are very happy to have to have door
there Minter speaking today doors done
remarkable work on several areas is very
well known for for his work on the
unique games conjecture and improved
that to to to conjecture also had
remarkable contributions to property
testing monotonicity testing and
recently resolving on on making progress
on some of the biggest open questions in
our asses boolean functions ready
finishes its PhD in just two years in
Tel Aviv University the last two years
he has been in the Institute for
Advanced Study in Princeton and is going
to start a position at MIT soon and I
think it will be on the fall in Simon's
Institute or at least in some a way or
fashion
so we are very happy to hear door
talking about the philanthropy
conjecture and so door the floor is all
all yours
and thank you very much I thank you all
for coming to this talk so I'm going to
talk about some new results about before
we end topic on your kill so this is
John Podesta Kelman guy kingdom normally
if it's a movie so fun so let's go
so before I even tell you what before we
enter the conjecture
let's set up some basics and so this
talk is internet for this particular
talk is internet for general audience so
please feel free to interrupt me any
point if you have any questions maybe we
should let them know that the questions
they can type
the stream and really probably tail yeah
so here are two things that are going to
be same from the stock so cloudy stock
will always consider the boolean
Hyperloop equipped with a uniform
measurement and enforce Moody I'm gonna
be lap times one convenient and will
study boolean functions F for me - one
one today and to Madison one and for
simplicity in this talk will only
consider balanced functions meaning
functions that get the value 1 and minus
1 equally likely of course all of what
I'm going to say has can generalized me
on this case but this is enough for
today and we start with a very basic
definition the diffusion of influences
so what is the influence of the if'
coordinate or the function f well the
influence of kaalia i f is the
probability that when I look at point x
chosen at random and at the point X plus
C I which is the same point as X except
that it's different on the ice called
the act then the inference of pi is the
probability that I get two different
values a in the function f so these are
influences and once we define these
probabilities you can certainly send a
noun and it is called they took the
influence of the function so at this
point it's not really clear what what is
why does it make sense to sum this up
but this total influences also goes by
several other names such as average
degree in a vergence at a meeting we'll
see why for the clicks one of them but
this is really key a parameter of a
function and sort of one of the key
questions in the area is the following
suppose the other William function and
I'm poor means that this function is
small to the influence so it doesn't
Francis is no scale what can you say
about its structure and for this
question you can think of K is coming
from several different regimes
so the first regime is where K is some
constant say a hundred but it also makes
sense to look at this question when K is
even log n say telegin or something like
that and I'm not going to elaborate on
that but this question does not appear
out of thin air
it appears in several places so for
example it appears in TCS for example in
PCP the pins in learning viewing
external cognitive Accenture thresholds
so this is certainly a question worth
studying
so the first regime in which this
question is interesting and also kind of
the easiest question in quotation mark
is when you think of K as a constant and
in this case we really have satisfactory
answer to this question and these
answers go by the name of the Coquille
filament continuum but before we say
fuse let's consider a few examples for
functions that satisfy this property to
get the hang of what we can expect so
here are two examples so how can you
arrange for the total influence over
function to be smaller your function can
depend only on one coordinate let's say
funcly' dictatorship the output of it is
simply the first coordinate of X the
next is see that all the variables
except the first one F zero entrance and
that okay influence is one in general
you can consider any function that
depends on your own K of its columns so
this
that known W&S phantasm and this will
also satisfy this poverty so these are
the two examples and what the cake is
doing this little interference a very
roughly speaking is that these are the
only examples so let's be a bit more
precise so here is the KLT whim so this
theorem says that if you have a function
whose total influence is smaller then at
least in some sense it resembles a
dictatorship in the sense that the
resistor variable within strands is
fairly significant and when I say
significant I mean like e to the minus K
so remember here here we think of cases
can hundred so e to the minus K is
around so this is a great feeling really
and actually we will say both for this
film loitering this in the slides but he
doesn't give you really satisfactory
answer because it's kind of kind of weak
structure you can hope to say mole and
indeed you can't say more and this is
exactly difficult for deaf children
so this theorem says that if you have a
function with small data in flames then
not only is there a variable with high
individual infants but in fact your
function essentially only depends on
these variables and sort of illustrate
Ford Coppola rain you get to say that F
essentially depends only on e to the K
many coordinates in wesen century this
is a bit informal the formal statement
is written on the slide but don't worry
about it too much what you should ever
mind is that F really depends on very
few audience but studies are really too
great fumes
and they're great for as long as case no
but that's it so once you pass this a
log in this cake was again both of these
films can become completely meaningless
like if K is log n into the K is modern
in but the input of the function is it
not available so what are we even saying
here acknowledge and this is a really
well-known very early in a nice when
functions that people sometimes called
the logarithmic burial because we know
to say many things about functions with
Tory influence is significantly smaller
a log annum
but essentially nothing and when we pass
this log in value
but so we say opening now I'm going to
tell you what organics a mystical it's
the first of all I'm going to have to
tell you a little more of basics for
analysis I'll try to do it in
steady-state just enough so that we can
State
before we end up a connection and then
tell you what are the main results that
we pull in this work then I'm going to
tell you about a very useful tool like
the main engine that that goes behind
all of these theorems which is called
the hyper compactive inequality today
I'm going to show you both the kicker's
Raven it's going to be useful for us and
finally I'm going to tell you about the
proofs of our results and the way it
will work is that the first hour of this
talk is will be dedicated to more of the
standard stuff of stating the results
and telling you the proof of the
ki-choon
which will be useful for us and in the
second level we will have both fun in
the sense that we start pulling things
and I'll show you how you can get some
new advance before we end of it yeah so
let's go ok so what is for analysis so
the starting point for analysis is to
look at all real valued functions over
the kill and to think of this as a
vector space so this is the thing we're
all done in linear algebra and although
some domain or another and what is nice
is to define an inner product so this
gives you lots of tourism and indeed we
define an inner product so the inner
product again two functions is the
expectation in a product
so therefore between F and G is the
expected value of f of X DX
and later on in the talk I'm going to
use some norms and whenever user normal
in a product it's always an expectation
good so the next basic thing about full
analysis is to choose a basis and with
the plus/minus foundations there is a
very natural basis to consider it seem
to lead the basis of monomials
so for each subset overlap of
coordinates s we define a function
caius from the cube to minus 1 1 which
is simply the product of X I when I is
in the set and a very standard fact
which is easy to prove is that if you
look at the disk election functions then
this is an orthonormal basis for the
vector space of real valued functions of
course we expect orient product we just
defined and so what do we know so we
know that a once we have an orthonormal
basis we can decompose any function
according to this in basis and this is
in this case called the Fourier
decomposition so we can write any real
valued function on the cube as a linear
combination of this character so this is
a dissertation of f of X as summation
over waves f hat as caius and because
this patient is so nice and it's also
normal
you get hopefully a very nice formula
for the coefficients of this
decomposition which was simply the inner
product between F and the corresponding
monomial
good so let's do a little basics so here
is a fact we have what is called a
passive a low natural inequalities and
what is I mean that if you have two
functions and you want to compute the
inner product between them then this is
the same as inner product wind is the
Fourier transforms up to normalization
so by that I mean that instead of
expectation of cotton in exam so I hope
that you've all seen a variant of this
equality one domain of another and when
a function is enjoyable saying this is
usually called the possible inequality
in a particular case of intervals will
be when F is equal to G is a boolean
function again by that we mean that it
is passed minus one value in this case
we get that inner product with
indefinite earth is on the one hand one
and on the other hand its summation of
of the squares of the Fourier
coefficients of F so I am i stressing
that well we're a bunch of non-negative
numbers would sum up to one we have a
name for this collection these are
distributions so we'll it will be useful
for us to think of this as distribution
so remember the square root of the foil
coefficients are distribution over
characters
so in particular you can ask about the
properties of them is a distribution
such as enthalpy ISM and other things
and indeed this is the parameters that
the foil conjecture address so now it
well enough basics we can state before
work and the conjecture of militant
Kalama but let's start with a moral
statement so the moral statement says
that if you have a function again a
boolean function that has small tota
influence at most km then it's
full-spectrum espouse in the sense that
almost all of the mass of f is
concentrated on e to the K many
coefficients so this is the molar
statement and if you don't want to think
about complicated formulas I suggest
that this is what you have in mind but
if you want to know what L cannot United
States then this is the following
statement it says that the reason
absolute constant C greater than 0 such
that for a boolean function if you look
at the Shannon entropy of 1/2 X square
then this is at most the total influence
of F times this absolute constant and
missioner entropy I mean the usual
general doping which is summation of H
squared log of 1 over F it's square
if you've never seen general and to
really encourage you to think about it
is like love the size of the support of
the distribution of course it's not the
same for the purposes of this talk it's
in earth yeah so - this is the finish
line connection so I studied this
conduction well so this is kind of the
first note we will study a result you
can ask about functions we've talking
friends tell again or something like
event so even coming up with statements
without in this function this is hard
and this is one very nice statement in
my opinion and the message here is you
know it's clear no inference implies
spouse it's very very clear so in some
special cases such as the inert form as
it is known to imply conjectures in
learning few weeks such as a difference
of induction and but I think that it'd
be fair to say that the original
motivation for freedom cry was for the
study of sharp thresholds so in
particular for gravities so there is
also relation Bella and material should
have said at a remark that if you only
care about functions have lots of
symmetry such as gafas bodies then there
are other statements such as the you
can't I let can bypass he says we will
conduct you and still get very good
results in actually so I'm not sure that
I will say little that I would say it
later but before Guernica is really
intimately related to the work that I'm
going to present today but it's yeah
it's a challenge - it's a challenging
exercise - to figure out our exactly
so door maybe I mean it's something that
would come up I guess again and again
but it's important to state that these
results sort of take take advantage or
really use the fact that the function is
boolean and are not right sort of not
true for functions that are just bounded
yeah so this is a good point yeah so
this is also certainly not true for
functions that arbitrary there is some
hope that you can come up with a
statement for like bounded functions
that will be equivalent to take
injection for we have functions but yeah
the sentence is does not hold for Obama
to thank you vision door there was a
question on the screen okay
wait presenter it's coming in a moment
[Music]
yeah so this conjecture is a still wide
open and you know to make focus on it
people suggested variants of the
conjecture that are weaker in the hope
of getting some results in a very
interesting sibling of it is what is
called before eminent of the conjecture
and you too O'Donnell and Biden a we can
guess what the conductor says instead of
Sharon and okay you mean it'll be other
than the statement is the same and again
the minion okay here is the minimum for
this log one of the affected squadrons
so this is a again a very interesting
statement it is weaker than before and
to the conjecture but stronger than the
calculus you win so it's somewhat in the
meter but despite that it just is wide
open
we don't know like we don't know
so what is not about this a conjecture
and what are the new results so there
are certainly been some work trying to
attack the conduction and I'm not going
to be exhaustive by any means I'm just
going to mention some things that I
remember those little to make it so the
conduction is being studied for classes
of functions such as symmetric functions
it was proven to be too too studied
foreign DNA formulas for read a constant
decision trees and also you can combine
a instances or the conjecture is done
and get in other way instances it is
known and also if you want to get a
bound with some maximum sensitivity
inserted into the picture then you can
also do that but I think it would be
fair to say that all of these results
are a bit far from establishing the
photo the connection and also there will
be some walks about the million topic
injection so there have been some
variants that will hold or we will place
to the influence you some other
complexity measures but again it's a bit
familiar itself but at least for the
minute topic on earlier you can say of
something that looks it least
aesthetically similar to the conjugate
service so you can prove that the minion
topi of effort square is at most
squirrel the data inference something
but the point is that this does not
really break the logarithmic value
because you can figure out it this just
follows from fluid feeling without much
difficulty so sort of misses the point
of the entire connection yeah so what am
I going to talk about so what is our
result so here is like Juan Cole area
we move that so all balanced boolean
functions it holds that the min and
abuse f it squared
is it most mister difference times love
totem joints so this this gets quite
close to the connection because you'll
need this log influence turn to get rid
of but you know it's still not the
production and sale you get some a nice
color isn't but it's not the result is a
bit stronger than that and in a moral
sense what we can always the the Shannon
entropy of then the distribution is its
most the same bound is it most to the
influence times love of arrangements and
this is mobile so this one only which
don't even never knows what what it
winds and to explain formally what I
mean by that I need to reduce a little
bit more basics good so we've had the
free expansion of a function we've read
this a notion of influences it make
sense to her to ask whether you can
express influences we sell some sort of
functions to the Fourier coefficients
and this is indeed possible it's it's
not hard so here is a lemma if you have
a boolean function and you want to know
what the influence of the eyes probable
is then this is exactly the sum squares
of Fourier coefficients over characters
that contain the viable I and if you
think about it makes a lot of sense
right we said it this is a distribution
so this sound factor that container is
exactly the mass that is put on
characters containing I it makes some
sense that this will have some relation
we inference and indeed is the case the
proof is not hard will not do it
and now we can at least explain to you
why total influence is sometimes called
devil giggling and this is for a very
simple reason if you take this lemma and
you sum it over all I you get the data
range from n sub F is equal to the
summation of all s of the size of s
times the foil coefficient of s squared
remember this is the distribution T
squared so this is really the expected
size of a character in the Forex
expansion of F so if if this is not if
this is not called every degree then
nothing will because Raj didn't write
this is the only thing that makes sense
and at this point I want to take to make
two remarks and it's a side remarks
meaning I will say them but then we
forget about them for a short time so I
want to say that now that we know that
the total influence is the average
degree we sort of have this image in
mind that functions we've loaded our
inferences a really function that are
approximated by logical polynomials
because if you know that the average
character size is K and you ask how much
mass is the untalkative more than K over
epsilon then you know that bamako
inequality this is no steps home so
functions that we study a really lovely
tour has some plus some L of course this
is all structured and correlated but
this is really what is happening so in
particular tools about closed upon
owners will be useful for us and this
will be hyper conductivity but I'm
jumping a bit ahead okay so I said this
is Saturn Ock so let's put it aside and
get back to state in the results so now
that we have this equivalent formula for
it obtained in France we can state an
equivalent formulation of the foyer of
the collection and it's equivalent
operation simply the places
with the problem that we have yeah so
what's the point of that
the point is only to make similarity
between the formulation of the
conjecture and our main result so here's
a theorem so we can pull that again for
all boolean functions if you look at the
Shannon entropy then it is it most this
expected Carter size except that you
bake some low-octave size in the tune so
for most visible functions this is the
same as total influence times a lot to
the inference but for some odd functions
it may not be the case but still yeah
sorry we have a question by Ryan yes the
figure of the ration about influence
isn't enough for the poor gain kalyra so
is it correct yeah because what you get
from the cake here is some login shop
freshmen but what you want for graph
would is a being squared so this is
exactly square that you lose good yeah
so so this is the what separates ask for
improving the conjecture is log X term
but this you can still get some things
of all of this filling and but actually
again now is that is a big motion Arab
and it's useful it we can say it so you
might wonder what happens if I look at
the Shannon entropy but after a certain
level up to level T and how does this
relate with living in France so we can
address this question so you can say so
yeah this is a bit a notation editing
but basically the message here is that
if you look at this point of the
conjecture we can truncate
of expressions at some level and
affricate the inequality holds except it
again we have this debate is global stir
plus some total influence it's not such
a big deal he's talking through instant
so in the people we have some o variants
and of some adult value if they do not
appeal to the paper but this is really
the main one yeah so so some
implications of this fill-in include
again something in the mobile sense of
the phone to work under here so we can
pull it if the total entrance of F is at
most K then the fourth second safest
spouse e to the K okay expose so again
we miss this lokah facto as a result we
get improved a performance for the low
degree learning are good for the class
of to him influence function and finally
you can even slightly improve the shop
facial results of poker and Callaghan so
Google I cannot quite cool log and
square the bountiful graph over this and
we get a bit closer to tool of its
Gordon good yeah so let's go back over
here so we've gone over the basics I
told you what the photo beacon actually
is I stepped the results and now we're
going to talk about hyper conductivity
but before that if there are any
questions and this is a good time so you
refer to you know the free entropy and
then the the easy way to remember it
which is you know concentrated on two to
the k coefficients and I see that one
implies the other but they are not
completely equivalent
you know they're not equally bad because
even if you have some small mass on some
coefficients they may contribute
arbitrarily to the enthalpy for example
you could say that just by free good you
get like a bound of you know 2 to the K
squared on the number of coefficients
but you don't get any bounds on down on
that let's refer to say good ok so let's
talk about hyper conductivity and again
we'll do it slowly so remember the side
remark that I told you about it so when
we are dealing with low inference
functions what we're really dealing with
is in lodi functions with some tail
after them and this begs the question of
what can we say about low degree
polynomials because maybe if we say can
say something interesting about them
maybe we can translate it to some
interesting observations about boolean
functions with no insurance so this is
another question with a multi linear
polynomial P 4 minus one month then to
pay listen a whose degree small say
Sandeep I want to put something for it
so what is sort of the most generic
things you can ask for you can ask for
concentration inequalities so let's go
to the the most basic case you can ask
about the case of dig liquids 1 and for
emily is you drink wine and it's like
one of those for 11 times the summation
of x i so in this case so we know how to
spoil a man behaves we know that its
values behavior flee like a standard io
shown by the central limit doing so
you're whatever you want your moment
bounty of tailbones
your vaunted concentration balance
everything that's good so let's say make
make it a bit much
so what about general Italy one case
what about general linear Hunan LP well
it does not have to be a black adoption
you can't have it all but I don't know
that you have everything that you want
you have normal pounds you have tables
and you have under consideration results
and fully stopped what will be important
is the moment balance so for example you
can prove the following model
I'll call it baby hyper-connectivity so
this theorem says that if you have again
be small given point of degree 1 and you
look at its 1/4 normal it's to learn
that these are roughly the same so it is
always the case that the fourth norm of
B is at least the 2 norm of B but what
is baby happen conductivity statement
tells you is that up to a can start
which happens to be squad of 3 these two
knowns are the same too hard to prove
but actually we have something not
enough but this is already called hyper
connectivity and this is a new toponymy
back doors it tells you that if now we
have a multi degree D no degree walk
then you still have roughly the same
statements we still have the form of P
and the tune of me be the same but you
pay moving the constant so it rest site
I encourage you to think of these
constant so then the fourth man of pin
to expel the same but if you want to be
a bit more precise then what you need to
note here is that the dependency on D is
exponential
ultimately this is what what a Gaussian
can be struggle with Macbeth but but
yeah this is already want to say for Mom
great so we have this applicant activity
and if you're anything like me when you
first series doing you may say okay
that's a nice inequality but so what
what does it even mean why should I care
about it
yeah so let's let me try to convince you
that it is useful yeah so high
productivity 101 so that's over a basic
fact so suppose we have a function on
the queue that gets the values minus 1 0
more and this function satisfies that
the probability it is nonzero is it
exactly data and letter should be four
of the small then the degree of P is at
least log one of the Delta not so
constant also let's see the proof of
this fact the proof is one line you
write down the habit would activate
equality you note that in this case you
can actually compute the form of even
turn three which are just dealt with
force and data tree have any way around
you take a log into whatever you need
and you get the result okay being very
nice but you may say okay so but don't
worry complicating life
this is just a corollary of the Schwartz
if I don't know which is a fair point
right and I this is one one it's not one
but the cool thing is that actually
roughly the same proof idea you get a
much stronger statement than this one so
you get this the following globus fact
which roughly speaking says that not
only is P of high degree but most of its
mass lies on high degrees so here is a
formal statement
if you look at this function again orbit
it is known as equal in Stella would you
smart and you look at the square root of
the foil coefficients that lie on low
levels and by low I mean less than love
1 over Delta then this is small this is
the most Delta to some power greater
than 1 say 9 or 8 and the point I want
to stress here is that if you look at
the entire foil coefficients of T then
they sum up to data by basketball and
here you get that on the low levels you
have much less than that so this really
is tells with it
not only is PFI degree but it is o
positive ID if that statement makes any
sense
yeah yeah so now we will prove this
robox fact and once we do that we'll be
halfway towards proving the theorem to
hear the poof so we wouldn't tell you
about the law degree part of me will say
that there is a little amongst them so
it makes sense to define this function G
which is exactly the Lodi grape out of P
then the mass that we want to talk about
is exactly the inner product between GMT
like by plan chillin in a member all we
have in our toolbox right now is the
basic I would conductivity if you win
and that requires us to have some for
phonons and you know off so let's invent
cell phone so we can learn a dinner put
it between gene P by holding equality by
the product of the form of gene times
the 4/3 norm of T we can then use in the
hypocotyl inequality to bound the fourth
north of a
and finally you can know that the tomb
of the is most 219 again very possible
and our done now all you need to do is
plug in the exact amount you have for
the various kinds of pay which again we
can compute as before we plug in the
degree of G and you're done so so I hope
it wasn't too quick but ok so this is
the only gotten some disease and you can
improve it in various ways but this
should be enough for us yeah good so now
hyper-connectivity 102 how do you use
this result to prove resolve such is the
case so this is what we'll do now I will
show you how to get the calcium from
this fact so here is again a statement
we want to prove that if the total and
so that is small then there is a
variable with relatively high influence
so let's do it
and we'll do it by the way of
contradiction so let's assume that all
of the influences no say all of them are
at most e to the minus hundred K now we
want to appeal to a low buzz fact so
what functions does it make sense to
define that will have small orbit of
being non zero some function that is non
zero only when you have influence and
the discrete derivatives are exactly
such functions so for each eye we define
risky derivative of F along Direction I
which is the difference between the
value of F at X and the value of F when
you flip that I've got
and you / - for normalization so you can
note two things very easily suppose the
world this is the minus 1 1 0 valid
function and secondly and if you want to
know what the Fourier transform of
distillery TB is it's very easy to see
see it's there on the slide so we would
like to use this robust fact already
scheduled with use and for that we need
to note that the probability of
derivative to be nonzero is smaller and
this is roughly equivalent to the
assumption that the influence small so
the probability of deliberative is
nonzero is exactly the same as the
influence of variable I which is at most
e to the minus carrot K therefore by the
robust fact we know that derivatives are
mostly high degree so let's back it up
we know that the mass of the derivative
that lies below level 10 carry is this
most influence to the 9 over it and it
will be convenient to break this
inference to the right all right down
into inference times inference to be the
one all right
inbound inference to the one over eight
by the Bandit we have but remember we
want to say something about the function
f so we want to say want to express this
in four weeks time of the coefficients
of derivative according to F but again
with the Fourier transform of
derivatives which they raise it then it
is exactly equal to the sum of squares
for coefficient of that contain high and
emphasized at most K and now the proof
is almost complete
all you do now is some basic idea of the
line and then you get a bit the total
mass of F below level 10k is it most
this e to the minus hundred K over eight
times the sum of inferences some of it
runs is the total inference to claim
things is most K so you get the this is
valid smell say it's smaller than 0.1
now we're done because we know that we
have total of mass one they mastered
lies on low levels is it mostly 0.1 so
it means that almost all of the mass
lies above level thinking so in
particular Devils Diggy has to be at
least a 0.9 times this 10 K I was well
0.9 of the mass above it and it is the
Bell meaning that they contribute and
this is more than K but remember every
degree is the same story in fringe which
is less than K so this is the
contradiction so this is how you pull
and you deca get a winner and kind of
the reason of the showing to you this
wolf is not only because it's nice
any is nice I think but also oh is that
our hope will be low meat in a non of
this way so authority to be good to see
it ok so let me summarize what we've
seen so far
so we've seen all the basics the
statements we talked about topic
motility
ok I showed you the proof of the KDF um
and I think that now will be a good time
for a break so after the break if you
didn't eat your we're nice its quota for
the day I'm going to tell you a little
bit about outpost and how do you use
these tools to analyze feudalism and
yeah so I think that this is it for now
and I want to thank you for your
attention so far and so if there are any
questions now is a good time otherwise
let's take a break until I don't know
when
[Music]
yeah Prasad hum like maybe we should
take that means break that sounds good
oh yeah we could give you ten minute
break do should we do questions out
after the break or you won't do it I
don't see any questions okay yeah let's
start cutting it but okay so great so I
hope to see many of you when we dive
into the details of the new results and
let's take a break to get some coffee
and I'm gonna pause the recording for
now so you can speak so so what have we
returning insurance let's say ten
minutes from now
so 1103 I guess one one more thing there
is a disc or channel which the link is
posted here they could want to continue
discussion there